un geste comme celui ci ça veut dire je
ne suis pas au dessus de toi tu n'es pas
au dessus de moi nous sommes à égalité
le tchèque que vous pratiquez peut-être
entre amis aujourd'hui c'est une chose
qui remonte aux années 60 aux états unis
au sein de la communauté africaine
américaine
enfin jeudi aux états unis en réalité ça
a commencé au vietnam
quand les etats unis sont en guerre au
vietnam il ya beaucoup d'africains
américains qui sont engagés très très
loin de chez eux avec parfois des
commandants et les chefs blancs qui sont
hostiles à leur encontre elle regard et
ils ont développé comme une sorte de
solidarité un signe particulier de
reconnaissance entre eux
qui va être le tchèque et qu'on appelle
aux états unis le dard dès midi une
pride dignité et fierté parce qu'il y à
un geste un signe de reconnaissance dans
ce geste qui dit en gros nous sommes en
chine ou je peux compter sur toi tu peux
compter sur moi
nous sommes à égalité nous sommes frères
fort et frère est en résistance aussi
contre les abus dont nous sommes
victimes en raison de la couleur de
notre peau et ce geste là ces soldats
américains une fois qu'ils vont rentrer
aux états unis
ils vont le ramener dans leur communauté
et c'est ainsi que dans les années 70 ce
geste va se diffuser énormément de
roulement un la poignée main le tchèque
s'est pas uniquement se serrer la main
ça dit quelque chose de plus et
d'ailleurs la toute première poignée de
main qu'on a attesté par une source elle
t'a du 9ème siècle avant jésus-christ
vous avez schyman hazard 3 le roi
d'assyrie qui est en guerre en
permanence avec lé roi babylonien mais
sur ce relief
il serre la main d'un roi babylonien
cette poignée de main
à droite celle qui ne peut pas tenir une
arme évidemment c'est le signe de la
paix le signe de la confiance et c'est
la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs en
diplomatie on n'a jamais cessé de se
serrer la main
aujourd'hui vous pouvez toujours
imaginer quand vous avez deux chefs
d'état qui se rend compte qu'ils se
retournent vers les photographes et qui
se serrent la main de manière claire
pour montrer qu'ils sont amis ils ne
sont pas forcément mais c'est un signe
de confiance réciproque c'est en tout
cas ce qu'on veut dire c'est pas
toujours le cas quand on pense par
exemple à la poignée de main historique
entre adolf hitler et le maréchal pétain
en 1940 elle signifie bien sûr bien sûr
la paix si vous voulez mais elle
signifie aussi qu'il ya un pays la
france qui accepte la domination d'un
autre donc on n'est pas forcément sur un
rapport d'égalité entre les deux qui se
serrent la main
après on sait pas vraiment comment la
poignée de main venir un bonjour
traditionnelles et classiques tels que
vous connaissez aujourd'hui certains
considèrent que ça se passe au xviiie
siècle aux états unis chez les quakers à
ces religieux considèrent qu' il n'y a
pas de différence entre les hommes n'y a
pas de niveau de supériorité ou
d'infériorité entre les hommes
et du coup la poignée de main c'est le
geste le plus neutre le plus le plus
égalitaire possible entre deux personnes
on se serre la main
c'est donc la preuve que personne n'est
au dessus de l'autre un signe d'égalité
entre deux individus et je serai ainsi
que la poignée de main ce serait
diffusée aux états unis
honnêtement on sait pas vraiment comment
elle s'est diffusée la poignée de
manteaux car elle est devenue à ce point
habituel et classique que par exemple au
moment de la grippe espagnole au tout
début du 20e siècle on est à la fin de
la première guerre mondiale en 1918 1919
vous avez des hommes politiques qui
interdisent
damman aux états unis la poignée de main
parce qu'on considère un peu comme
aujourd'hui que la peau et les mains
elle a diffusé la malasie diffuser le
virus l'heure si un peu plus serrée 1
devra inventer autre chose et là on a
des modèles ailleurs je pense on a un
vaste et dans les pays du sous-continent
indien
le wa et en thaïlande aussi on s'incline
chez les égyptiens l'antiquité on
serrait pas la main on plie un peu les
jours en mettez les mains sur les genoux
en signe de bon jour donc il ya plein de
possibilités il ya plein de pratiques
différentes mais c'est vrai que la
pratique de serrer la main
aujourd'hui peut-être qu'elle va
disparaître ça serait en tout cas une
évolution intéressante puisque ce comme
je voulais dit ça fait plus de trois
mille ans qu'on serre la main